The Waimakariri District Council meeting for
December was recently held, and before getting
to down to business, the Councillors and Mayor
David Ayers had the pleasure of presenting
a Community Service Award to Kaiapoi resident,
John Rose.
John was recognized for his volunteer efforts
in the community, including his work with
North Canterbury Mini Bus Trust.
The Council then moved on to deputations and
presentations, and heard from both Andrew
Gough, a resident of Swannanoa and developer,
Bevan Hames, on the proposal to reduce a section
of Tram Road from 100km to 80km.
After considerable debate, council approved
the recommendation that the speed limit be
reduced from 100km/h to 80km/h on Tram Road
from 500m east of the Bradley Road / McHughs
Road intersection to 300m west of that intersection.
Council also approved an expansion of options
to the kerbside collection service to be added
into the Waste Management and Minimisation
plan 2017.
After a large amount of public consultation,
Option C has been chosen as the preferred
option, which allows users a choice of new
rates-funded bins for rubbish and organics,
or sticking with the user-pays rubbish bags
and rates-funded recycling bin they currently use.
The final details of the proposed new kerbside
collection service will be presented to the
Council in the final draft Waste Minimisation
Plan next year after the 2018-2028 Long Term
Plan has been approved.
Council also adopted the Northern Pegasus
Bay Bylaw 2016 implementation plan, which
includes the establishment of the Northern
Pegasus Bay advisory group.
This group will be chaired by Councillor Al
Blackie.
And Council approved the legal stopping and
physical removal of Hood Avenue and Clarke
Avenue in The Pines Beach area.
The removal of these now redundant roads is
another step forward in the Regeneration process.
This meeting was the last for the year, with
Council’s first ordinary meeting in the
new year on Tuesday 6th February.